all right let's get into our mailbag
it's the Friday mailbag you can email
info davidpackman.com if you have a
question comment concern anything you
want to demand a correction for
occasionally we will grab a comment from
YouTube or sometimes Facebook or
sometimes a tweet or whatever the case
may be uh let's get right into it as we
often do starting with some criticisms
which is fine DL or Patrick I don't know
wrote in and says Biden should be in
jail family corrupt over 40 years Where
Have You Been maybe you haven't been
around long enough please read all info
on Biden's laptop both dad and son
should be in prison for all their
dealings with China Ukraine and other
countries they have made Millions from
money laundering I know you know this
with a question mark
this is the type of person where
we just need there's not enough time
between now and the election to talk
sense into someone like this
so my advice from a voting standpoint is
we just have to find two new voters to
cancel out this guy's vote I mean one I
guess to cancel it out but then a second
one to actually make some progress I
don't see how someone who
is in such a fantasy world that their
one contact with me is to tell me how
everything about my perspective is wrong
because it lacks the stuff from the
Biden laptop and Biden and Hunter should
be in prison that I don't think we have
the the time capacity
to just argue and change these people's
minds if you think there's some way to
fix these folks brains
let me know but I think it's much
simpler to register people to vote and
to uh cancel out their votes next
message is from Cara Cara wrote it and
said you're a effing Nazi beta boy well
I'm Jewish
so I don't know what you mean by Nazi
but my family fled the Nazis
Kara goes on there are hundreds of
millions of trumpies who will make sure
your voice is silenced on social media
as ours have been who the f are you
well if you don't even know who I am
why is it important that hundreds and
millions hundreds of millions of
trumpies silence me
if I'm so insignificant that Cara has
not heard of me I don't know why anyone
would need to waste any time silencing
me by the way it's really interesting
how the the delusions seem to spread
virally and what I mean by that is
recently Trump pulled this idea that
there's hundreds of millions of Maga
people at his last rally Trump said
something like oh there were the 75
million who voted for me plus another
150 million probably like so there so
Trump believes that there's 225 million
trumpists
um in the United States now correct me
if I'm wrong
number of adults in USA 2022
uh what are the number of adults
I actually can't find that anyway the
point is 225 million magats is like it's
got to be close to every adult I don't
know what percentage of the population
is under 18 but it's got to be 20 or or
more anyway as usual as is the case with
these people The Numbers Never add up
the Numbers Never add up thank you cara
I appreciate that okay Mike wrote in
again asking about these spam messages
that he's getting Mike says I've
received this message a couple of times
in response to comments made on Dave
Pacman YouTube clips question is scam or
legit
I don't use WhatsApp but I am curious
and it's one of these messages where the
user has my
a picture as their profile picture and
it says write me
I know that this is a disappointment to
some in the audience some people will
write to me and say David I was so
excited that you wanted to hear more
from me about my view on you know
Hillary Clinton or whatever that I tried
writing you on WhatsApp like you told me
I am not asking anyone to text me
or to Whatsapp me or anything
these are scammers report them to
YouTube we are doing everything we can
to get this Scourge As Trump would like
to say
off of YouTube
as far as I know no one's been scammed
so far but eventually they will ask you
for money that's the scam and at some
point I'll do an expose a bigger picture
on on the full scam but no I'm not
whatsapping anybody I'm not texting
anybody I don't want you to text or
Whatsapp me it is a scam do not fall for
it Jaden noticed an anomaly on our uh
social blade page which tracks our
YouTube channel Jaden said David sir I
was looking at the social blade for your
YouTube channel and I noticed it as a
graph of your subscriber increases
I have tears in my eyes as I tell you
that it appears that the machines have
been dumping you subscribers of ten
thousand every couple weeks there are
huge gaps and irregularities that cannot
be explained please sir we need pillow
on the show so he can explain how the
machines did this yeah you know a few
people have written to me and they said
David
is there a scam going on with your
subscribers because it you get none for
days and then suddenly ten thousand in
one day let me explain
on YouTube once you get to a million
subscribers
uh the algorithm shifts into tracking
them in tens of thousands so like when
you look at our YouTube channel it'll
say
1.47 million subscribers and then it'll
go to 1.48 so it tracks them in 10 000
increments when that is the case
socialblade does the same thing so in
reality we get like 600 subscribers a
day
but it only updates now every ten
thousand no scam going on check any
channel above a million subscribers and
you will see it's the same Michael
Rhoden Michael says David I sincerely
want to thank you for the public service
you do in showing the liars and
hypocrites on your show I think it's
very necessary but I can't bear to watch
some of the outrageous Clips you show so
I mute the sound and just listen to your
commentary to learn what nonsense was
said you must have a great deal of
self-control to be able to listen to
Trump and the magas day in and day out
well I don't know if this is a good
thing or a bad thing I've talked about
this before
there is a desensitization that happens
when you do what I do
where because outrageous things happen
so often they start to seem less
outrageous and that's why it's good
number one to take time away from this
stuff
and number two to talk to people from
different places so when I talk to
family of mine from other countries or
even when foreign callers call in or
when I read articles about American
politics from other countries
it's always good to have sort of your
sensibilities reset because it's nuts
here this Maga right-wing authoritarian
wannabe fascist movement that is written
about here by Michael
these people are genuinely dangerous and
it's also not typical it's really not
typical and it's good to get that
perspective from other countries Daniel
wrote in about Mike pillow
and says David do you really think it's
appropriate to have Mike Lindell on your
show again after his manic episode on
Facebook it's clear Mike is unwell
inviting him on again almost seems wrong
like we're making fun of someone who
needs a doctor anyway just a thought let
me know what you think Daniel from
Indiana says don't have pillow on
because he's he's mentally ill uh I I
mean I don't know that we know that
and honestly probably like 20 of our
guests are mentally ill by some
definition I don't know I don't know
what the standard should be
it's a tough one but I'm willing to hear
from people in the audience Aaron wrote
in and uh writes in about CNN's right
turn Aaron says hi David I'm a
progressive possibly a little to your
left on some issues but I have to say
that I'm not scandalized by CNN's
decision to drop the big live moniker
even though it's very clearly a big lie
don't you agree that the term sounds
quite editorialistic for a new segment
I'm not convinced that a commitment to
more neutral language is in fact a turn
to the right now listen on the CNN right
turn it's no one thing
it's not oh we're dropping the big lie
alone
It's a combination of things including
statements made by the new CEO or
president whatever he calls himself
um the big lie thing is one Element
changes to Staffing it's a lot of
different things recent comments from
anchors I would never make the case that
just based on not using the term big lie
anymore CNN is now Fox News that
wouldn't be uh accurate it's not what I
believe but go back to the segment I did
on it and it's a much bigger picture
issue than that
Rodney wrote in about abortion and said
hello should a registered or voting
Republican be allowed to get an abortion
in the United States I get the point of
this question
if you vote against abortion being legal
by voting for elected officials who will
try to make it illegal should you be
allowed to get an abortion it is so
outside of any legal framework to deny
abortions based on how people vote that
my opinion is here's Here's my thought
Rodney okay and and I really appreciate
the message I get why you're asking the
question
it's a losing direction to go in saying
okay
make abortions illegal for Republicans
because they want it to be we're almost
as bad in saying deny a legal medical
procedure to people right and so no I
don't think that that's a good idea at
all Gabriella wrote in about Democrats
quote winning and and she makes a good
point
Gabriella says hello sir my dad used to
tell me when I would ask who's winning
during any sports game well no one wins
until the end they're only ahead for now
I thought this might be relevant to your
recent clip on Democrats leading across
the country albeit not by enough they're
ahead for now but it's up to voters to
help them win a hundred percent correct
and this is why every time we look at
2022 polling numbers Senate forecast
house forecast I always say
this is where we are right now there are
things not yet reflected in the polls
everyone must vote everyone must vote
and I hope that you will
and uh we're starting to get down to the
wire if you have never voted before at
least Google voter registration deadline
in your state and understand when can
you register can you register same day
it's very important to know that and I
hope every single one of you votes all
right Monday 9 19.
David packman show membership special
we're going to be blowing out
memberships at rates never seen before
at a huge discount the theme is 919
that's the date if you would like to be
notified about this membership special
you need only get on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com we'll see you on the
bonus show and back here on Monday